and now a short film by les and they
also this is crazy feel Stockman
[Music]
Christie field Stockman likes the supe
he reaches into the caviar for the supe
he wants to make this super he admires
the supe
but he cannot make the supe because
there never was any supe moonrise
kingdom is the newest Wes Anderson film
it stars Bruce Willis Edward Norton
Frances McDormand Bill Murray Tilda
Swinton Jason Schwartzman such a good
cast and I feel like I should tell you
guys this before I get into my review
I've gotten like endless requests to
review this movie and I don't live in LA
I don't live in New York I live near
Cleveland Ohio I saw this film as soon
as possible I saw the very first
screening held in Cleveland if it's a
very limited release film I'm not gonna
be able to see it at first I personally
you guys know I will see it as soon as
possible that is my I am determined to
see as many films as I can for you guys
but I politely request that you provide
me with a little more time for the
limited releases before you start
screaming at me moonrise kingdom is
about these two young kids and their
various stranged from everyone that's
involved with their lives their family
their friends and they strike up a
connection with each other and they
decide to flee from their respective
places of which they reside the boy from
his khaki scout troop led by Edward
Norton and the girl from her parents
played by Bill Murray and Frances
McDorman they meet in the woods and they
try to see if they can survive this area
you know it's like a test of their young
love Bruce Willis is a member of the
island police and he's trying to find
them Edward Norton as I said is the
Scout troop leader he's trying to find
them everyone's trying to find these
kids and it's very different and
original fantasy like adventure moonrise
kingdom is one of the best films I've
seen all year I adored this movie it was
so good it was so funny and clever and
witty let's talk a little bit about the
direction by Wes Anderson immaculately
framed just beautifully framed the pans
the zooms everything is so smooth the
camera just flawlessly glides along this
atmosphere this movie creates the use of
color in this movie mostly brown yellow
green create a very nature like setting
for everything it's extremely pleasing
to the eye the pacing in this movie is
terrific there really
never a dull moment I was laughing my
butt off so often during this movie from
scene to scene to scene consistent
hilarious moments it's it's just so much
fun to watch also very briefly knew in
the beginning its told slightly in a
nonlinear fashion I really liked it it
didn't seem like a gimmick it actually
helped the story let's talk a little bit
about the script in the story the
dialogue is so fresh here it's a so
funny and clever and really a lot of the
funniest stuff comes from the fact that
it's kids very young kids seeing and
doing very adult things I mean they're
just they're acting like grown-ups you
know there's this great scene I'm not
gonna spoil it but there's just this
great scene that reminded me so much of
the standoff in the Sandlot where
they're trading insults back and forth
uh it was so funny it was just great I
love that there's one of the best scenes
in the movie also the movie has a lot of
really over-the-top fantastical elements
to it that you wouldn't think would work
normally but the movie really treats
itself as this very strange fantasy
comedy in a way and it's really clear
that Wes Anderson and Roman Coppola had
a really good idea of that they were
very self-aware of where they were going
in the script and so the audience can
then relish and he's extremely like
impossible moments that are just so
funny because you could tell they
understood the direction they were going
in each character is given the needed
depth and background information and
just the emotion that is required to
flesh them out so that we can start
caring for them even though so many
strange things are happening in this
movie you really start to care for these
people the standouts for me were Bruce
Willis in this movie Wow
it was great because at times it was
like he was mocking his past image as
this big action star and that was so
cool to see Bill Murray
dear Lord he is funny in this movie I
mean him and Wes Anderson go together
kind of like Johnny Depp in Tim Burton I
mean he just works so well in this
universe that Wes Anderson has created
he was awkwardly funny you know he just
says these things where he's just
standing there he just says it you're
like god this is so funny but it either
only because he said it I'll be out back
find a tree to chop down an Edward
Norton class actor I mean you guys know
Edward Norton is fantastic he's playing
against type 2 a lot of times Edward
Norton plays like these hardened
characters you know these guys who've
seen a lot they could kill you or
something like a Fight Club in 25th hour
and then you know American History X and
here he's like this little timid guy
he's this Scout troop leader who says
stuff like Jiminy Cricket he flew the
coop now let's talk a little bit about
the to me
kids in this movie now this is honestly
where this movie could fail because the
entire emotional structure of this movie
is really riding on these two kids
fantastic they were clearly directed
very well I like the performances they
fit right into this universe that Wes
Anderson created they were great in the
movie I liked their chemistry with one
another I bought the fact that there
were these two kids that liked each
other it just worked they brought the
needed warmth the right amount of
quirkiness and even the right amount of
sadness really they just had the right
amount of everything movie also pushed
the boundaries a little bit like it
actually had a few scenes in the movie
that were very shocking and surprising
they got away with it I was I always
respect directors when they do that they
when they have the balls to put a scene
in a movie they were like I don't know
if I'd I don't know about that one I
don't think I could do that but Wes
Anderson good for you buddy you got
balls man I was riveted by the third act
of this movie throughout the whole movie
there's this impending hurricane you
keep hearing about you keep hearing
about and once stuff starts going on you
realize how that relates to certain
relationships there in the movie how
it's kind of like a weird metaphor I
like to get all metaphorical on my
channel and everything I saw a lot of
different themes in this movie things
they use to describe where certain
things were going and if you don't pick
up on it it'll just blow right past you
but even if you don't pick up on all
those little hints and things you're
still gonna enjoy this movie because
it's endlessly entertaining the movie is
inner spliced with these really funny
sequences with Bob Balaban you know the
little guy he's kind of like appears in
everything ever since Close Encounters
of the Third Kind even he's just
standing there in the frame just talking
about what's about to happen no reason
at all for it to be there but it is so
funny and it just it's so different you
know it's just so different and original
it's so great to see a film that it's
just not the same old thing you've seen
a thousand times the musical score in
this movie is fantastic in the
background sometimes you feel it like
it's carrying you along but then at
times it just brings the scenes to this
whole other level where you're like wow
that really added something I mean I
love when musical scores help a movie
progress the story that's really what a
musical score is meant to do I love
listening to movie scores but the ones
that really propel the story along are
the best ones I thought about this movie
for an entire day and I cannot find one
thing I didn't like about this movie I
adored moonrise kingdom and that's why
moonrise kingdom gets an A+
you guys need a chance to see this movie
see it immediately God to the theaters
watch it it's freakin hilarious I loved
it it looks beautiful the shots the
direction the writing everything the
acting just everything just fits to
create this wholly original movie and I
loved it it's the best Wes Anderson
movie I've ever seen I adored it
fantastic film check it out and just let
you know my Batman Returns review with
the schmoes is on my channel right now
or in the middle of our giant
collaboration check it out let us know
what you think and as always guys if you
like this review can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]